hey everyone thanks for coming I'm max
as was said I'm from San Francisco a
place it's almost as beautiful as
Iceland on a nice day this is a picture
of one of my favorite places there today
we're going to be talking about
Bluetooth Harald Bluetooth was a king of
denmark and norway in the 10th century
AD he's widely known as the inventor of
Bluetooth technology but there are no
Bluetooth devices in his day so the
technology went on used for hundreds of
years actually not quite we're going to
be talking about bluetooth low energy
which is a variant of Bluetooth 4.2 'the
smart it was originally developed by
nokia in the early 2000s for lower power
lower bandwidth devices like sensors and
what we now call the Internet of Things
bluetooth low energy can be thought of
as a hierarchy of key value pairs what
we call is the generic attribute profile
and short for a gap so let's take a look
at what this looks like so for example
let's say we have a heart rate wristband
and get terminology we would call that a
gat server because it's what we connect
to a GATT server contains a collection
of services for instance this server has
device information such as the vendor
serial number inversion live heart rate
data and a battery service which we can
get battery up-to-date battery info from
each of these services has a unique
identifier which we can use to request
it from the device a service contains a
collection of characteristics for
instance the heart rate service has live
heart rate measurement data and body
sensor location in this case the body
sensor location would be the risk
because this is a wristband services are
really important for Bluetooth discovery
when you want to find a device to
connect to you do that by looking for a
specific service a service provides
interoperability between different
devices by different manufacturers
because it's like a schema if you have a
heart rate service it'll be the same no
matter what device you are talking to so
for instance a client like a phone can
look for a heart rate service and if
there's a device that is offering the
heart rate service out there it will be
broadcasting it'll be advertising hey
I've got heart rate service and then the
client can start a connection with them
web bluetooth is a relatively new
development it's available right now in
as flagged in Google Chrome so if you
have google chrome stable you probably
already have a browser which supports
web bluetooth but it's still very
experimental it's still changing and
there may be unpredictability or even
the potential for undiscovered security
issues so it's still you know hold on to
your horses and it is also under
development in the servo browser engine
so now let's take a look and make our
first connection to a Bluetooth device
this is called oh my oh I'm wearing one
right here the Myo is a ring of
electrical contacts and it's based it is
able to detect electrical changes on
your skin and recognize like crude arm
gestures like if I make a fist it can
recognize that and let's step through in
the console how to connect to this Maya
and we're going to do this live the Maya
this is what the Maya looks like in
terms of services and and
characteristics there's a command
characteristic which we can write values
to to send commands to the device and
there's a gesture characteristic which
we can use to observe live gestures from
here's the ideas for those services and
as I advance the slides this these
commands are going to be running live in
the console dunno life so the first
thing we need to do too is we need to
find or discover the Myo device the Myo
device is broadcasting hey I've got the
Myo control service so what we're going
to do is call navigator bluetooth dart
request device and what we do is we pass
it a filters object and the filters is
basically describing what the device
looks like that we want to connect to we
also need to specify the gesture service
here because we're going to need to
access it later we need to specify up
front all the servers were going
services we're going to access on the
device so when we run this code you'll
see there's now a pop-up here that is
offering to connect to the DeMaio on my
arm this navigator Bluetooth dot request
device requires user interaction so you
need to have it connected to a mouse
click or a key press we'll talk a little
bit more about that later when I press
the connect button the promise that is
returned by a request device will
resolve
and as you see we've successfully got
just a representation of a Bluetooth
device here but we haven't connected to
it yet to do that we call a gap connect
on it let's give that a shot and let's
wait cool okay so now we're actually
connected to the device let's take
another look at what the services and
characteristics look like as a demo I'd
like to show how to read and observe
gestures from the device so what we need
to do is drill down into the GATT
hierarchy and get the gesture service
and then the gesture characteristic from
that to get the service we call get
primary service with the idea of the
service that we want that returns a gat
service object and then we want to drill
down and get the characteristic we call
get characteristic on the service with
the idea of the characteristic we're
interested in characteristics are the
values of the key value pairs in the
hierarchy now that we have a reference
to this characteristic we need to do two
things we need to ask the device to
notify us as the characteristic value
changes and then we can set up an event
listener that will print out the
gestures as they received from the
device I'm calling a function here
called par smile gesture because the
data you get from these characteristics
is an encoded binary you have to decode
it and interpret it into a higher level
JavaScript form that's nice for us to
work with so when I press the next
button in advance the slide hopefully we
should receive gestures from the device
I'm going to make a fist with my hand
uh-oh oh no that's okay there's one more
thing that we have to do we need to send
a command to the mile telling it please
start recognizing gestures and sending
them to me this is something specific to
the mile we're turning on its internal
classifier but this is a great example
of how to write a value to a
characteristic to do that we're going to
need to encode a binary characteristic
command value we do this using typed
arrays as you can see this is a five
byte array notably the last the last
bite of the array is the value one and
in the for the Myo that means please
turn on the gesture classifier and
that's what it looks like on the console
finally we're going to write this
command
please turn on the carrot the recognizer
to the to the control service of the
Maya this is a this is similar to before
but we're just using a lot of promise
changing the entire web Bluetooth API is
a lot of promises because each of these
steps could involve asynchrony so we're
getting the primaries we're getting the
service for the control service then
we're drilling down into the
characteristic for sending commands and
finally we're writing a value to the
command characteristic which is the
gestures command we have up here and now
we have live Bluetooth data from the
Mayo so the model can recognize a couple
things if I spread my fingers I can also
make a fist I can wave in I can wave out
and I can tap my fingers maybe magic
this is so freaking cool oh my gosh like
the first time I got this working was
amazing because i've had this my 0
device for about like one or two years
and i've never been able to use it on
linux because the manufacturer never
made a device driver for linux but here
in just like what like 15 lines of code
we have a connection to the device and
we're able to get gestures off it this
is magical let's talk more about what's
going on here so from the mile which is
like many of the bluetooth devices i'll
show you today we're essentially getting
a real time stream of data updates from
the device if you're familiar with any
functional reactive programming perhaps
you've come across this concept of a
stream before but you may be thinking of
something that looks more like this or
maybe this but uh that's okay here's an
introduction of how to work with streams
in reactive mind set we're going to use
a library called extreme for this here's
how to create a stream that will
immediately emit five events the numbers
one through five as JavaScript objects
there we go but the stream is not going
to do anything until we add our first
listener to it a stream can be basically
thought of as a value changing over time
or a periodic sequence of events the
stream listener is basically three
callbacks a callback that is called when
a new value is emitted from the stream a
fatal error call back and a call back
when the stream is complete and will no
longer emit any values so what we have
here is a utility function that will
print out on the console when each of
these callbacks is called so if we try
that on our numbers stream as expected
we get the numbers one through five and
then the stream completes but where
streams get really powerful got a got a
key into this Maya gesture here is when
you can use them to manipulate data and
create data flows stream processes by
which we're transforming the data so for
example we can create a new stream of
the values x 10 based on our original
stream by mapping a function over it so
in here we're mapping x 10 to our stream
and we're printing it out maybe I should
switch back to the keyboard as you can
see now we have printed out the numbers
1 through 10 through 50 and the stream
completes but where this gets really
interesting is asynchrony this time
let's try printing out the numbers one
through five but let's wait a second in
between each in between each increment
access periodic will give us a stream
that waits a certain amount of time and
will count up into infinity but we don't
want to count into infinity we want to
count up to the number five so we can
create another stream called finished
that weight that filters out any values
that are less that are not greater than
five so the first value will emit is
when the count reaches six and then we
can end our original stream the count
stream when six is emitted so then we
can just get the numbers one through
five waiting a second in between mitts
and then the stream completes cool
wouldn't it be cool if we could treat
Bluetooth devices like uh like streams
I've been tinkering with a library for
doing this the first thing we give this
library is a description of the device
we'd like to connect to this looks like
the call to navigator dot bluetooth that
request device we're passing in filters
and optional services but now we give it
a listen object that's a description of
the services and characteristics and
those services that we want to observe
as a stream and what this library does
is it it gets that characteristic it
starts notifications running from them
and it hooks up an event listener and it
emits those events as a stream and if
the device disconnects it will reconnect
automatically so here is a view of the
live data coming off of the Myo device
on my arm it we're printing it out in
hex format and if I make a fist you can
see the value changes from 0 to 1 and
we're using this library to we're just
pulling out the the gesture service and
gesture characteristic as a stream but
that's not very nice to look at or code
with so to parse this Milo gesture
here's an example of how you can decode
one of these binary events we have a
mapping from from values to string
gestures and we're just going to get the
the value of the gesture in binary from
the mile look it up on our table and
return the value if we have a match and
that's what this looks like so now we
have a live stream of high-level like
easy to work with gesture data you'll
notice there's kind of a funny dollar
sign after raw gesture that's how that's
a convention for indicating whoops have
to get a little bit less less excited
with my arms that's a convention the
dollar sign tells us that the variable
we are working with is a stream and as
we've see in the slides to follow all of
these slides are transforming one stream
of data into another stream of data and
processing it as we go let's look at a
second device
this is a Bluetooth heart rate monitor
the way it works is it shines a green
light into your wrist and it detects the
my new changes in color from blood
pumping into and out of your skin out of
your veins in underneath your skin this
device is similar to the mile we're
looking for a device this time that is
advertising the heart rate service and
we're going to pull we're going to dig
into it and get the heart rate
measurement characteristic from there
you'll notice that instead of a variable
where I'm holding an ID for these
services and characteristics we're just
passing a plain old JavaScript strings
in here the reason is the heart rate
service and heart rate characteristic
are standard services provided by the
bluetooth sig on back to that in a
moment here's the binary data coming off
of the heart rate heart rate stream
coming straight from my arm right now so
you may be wondering where you find
information about these binary
representations and what kind of
services and characteristics there are
this is a website from the bluetooth sig
where they describe each of these
characteristics and the data formats
inside so we can drill down the
characteristics listing to find heart
rate measurement and then when we go
look into their we find a table
describing what each byte does and how
to interpret it what the what the
description is what the units are etc
and this is what the heart rate
measurement one looks like and then you
can turn that into a big old JavaScript
function we're not going to go into the
details here but what's interesting
about this function is it's actually
straight from the web bluetooth spec
draft it's used as an example there so
if we apply this parse heart rate
function to our stream of binary data we
can get a live feed of heart rate data
as a stream you can see here that
there's the the heart rate value that's
in beats per minute and there's also our
hour intervals which is the amount of
time in between each heart rate pulse
now we're going to look at the last and
most exciting device for me which is a
bicycle sensor this bicycle sensor sits
on the chainstay of your bike we have
one right here and it basically there's
there's a there's two magnets on this
bike there's a magnet on the on the
crank here by the pedal and there's a
magnet on the spoke of the bike and as
these magnets pass by the bike sensor
it's going to count how many times how
many times they've passed by frankly
it's a glorified stopwatch but a
stopwatch isn't a very useful piece of
data to to work with to connect to the
cycling cycle sensor we're going to use
the cycling speed and cadence service
which this device advertises and as you
can see these are all so friendly string
names so this is a standard service that
you can you can refer to by its its its
name alias when you're using the web
Bluetooth API so let's look at the
binary data coming off of the device if
I give the wheel a turn we should see it
update in a moment cool so what it's
doing we can try turning the crank as
well really exciting alright it will get
more exciting a moment I'm going to save
us the trouble of you know writing a
parser for this and jump straight to the
abstract data we're getting off of the
device as you can see if I give the
wheel another turn you're going to see
indeed that the the revolutions of the
wheel are ticking up and when I turn the
crank the crank revolutions take up as
well and we also have time stamps for
those values which we can use to
calculate the speed of rotation but
first let's uh let's calculate distance
distance is really easy we take the
circumference of the wheel and multiply
it by how many times it's turned around
and then we can get a stream of the
distance traveled we'll use this in our
in our bike computer if we're going to
display it to the to the rider and this
is in kilometers
cool now let's figure out how to create
a stream of the speed of the bike
because that's what we're really
interested in going fast we want to
measure the speed first of all in
revolutions per minute the number of
times the bicycle wheel goes around to
do that we're going to take two samples
we're going to look at like over time
how much how many times the wheel is
rotated over how much time but we
haven't looked at a history yet in the
context of the stream how do we get that
previous value because currently the
streams I've shown you so far are just
the current most live value emitted
every time well excess extreme has us
covered here with an operator called
pairwise and this operator you basically
apply it to your stream and it
transforms your stream into a new form
that emits different types of values
what pairwise does is it will emit
consecutive values as array pairs of a
stream so if we call print stream on
this you can see 1 2 2 2 2 3 3 to 4 etc
so we can use this to pair up our
samples of data from the bicycle
computer and we can use that to
calculate rpm first we're going to do
cadence cyclists like to know how
quickly they're turning their how
quickly they're turning the pedals and
we measure that as cadence directly as
rpm so this is how quickly I'm turning
the pedals right now yeah but for the
speed of the wheel Oh what you see
happening here is we're taking the pairs
of samples and we're just doing a little
bit object plunging before we pass it
into utility that does the math for us
we're pulling out the the crank
revolutions from the first sample and
then the crank revolutions from the
second sample and then the function revs
to rpm is going to just do the math
comparing how much time has passed and
how many cranks have happened we can do
that for speed as well so if i turn the
wheel we can get our PM off of the wheel
and finally what we want to do is
convert convert that RPM to km/h and we
do that by multiplying it by the
circumference of the wheel giving
how much how much distance we were
travelling over time let's give this
another world oops yeah so there there
you have it we've created four streams
of data now coming off of this bike I'll
end my arm this is all completely live
you can see my heart rate is going in a
nice 120 beats per minute everyone's
favorite electronic music tempo and as
we interact with the bike we can get a
live data off of it if we take a goals I
view of what's going on here we've taken
we've connected to a heart rate sensor
here we've converted a stream of binary
data into abstract heart rate data
similarly we've connected to the bicycle
sensor and we've got a system of streams
that are all you know one step in the
data processing flow oops yeah so based
on the ABS on the parsed revolution
counts and time stamps we can derive the
distance travel the wheel rpm the crank
rpm and from the wheel rpm we can do a
little math and get the km/h and now we
have four streams of bicycle information
there's one last step to make a awesome
bicycle computer which is we need to
pipe this all into the Dom somehow we
can use handlebars j/s for this get it
just kidding instead we're going to use
cycle jas for this there's no relation
between cycle jets and bicycle jets by
the way which is the name of this talk
cycle j/s is a really cool library for
building applications and behavior
systems out of streams in cycle j/s your
view is also a stream so we take our
stream of all these like four different
cycling metrics that we've collected up
and we transform that stream into
virtual Dom and when our stream emits
virtual Dom in this case the component
bicycle j/s each emitted virtual Dom get
stiffed with the current state of the
page and the page gets updated and in
the end we get something that looks like
this I'd like to give it a spin
now it's very important to wear a helmet
oh sorry it's very important to wear a
helmet when you ride a bicycle someone
once told me that your head is about the
toughness of a ripe watermelon so keep
that in mind and be safe it's also
really important to wear shades when
you're bicycling because it looks cool
and oh wow I should have probably should
have toned down the gestures but it's
cool we've got wireless control because
it's Bluetooth so everything's fine
let's give this a spin this is my
everyday ride you guys just riding along
and harpa really cool so now you have it
somehow we managed to go in the negative
distance but you know time travel and
we've got some cool graphs everything
works great so that's that's bicycle jas
thank you now as you saw by my my rudely
advancing the slide too early the point
I'm trying to make about all this is
that the web is changing rather our
expectations for the web are expanding
bicycle j/s is an example of a web app
that can run pretty much like a native
app on your phone it works offline
thanks to a service worker and it
connects natively to your Bluetooth
devices this is previously something
that was a task relegated to native iOS
and Android devices in fact for any of
these gadgets many of which you may own
you have the first thing you do when
you're setting up one of these gadgets
is you download and install and iOS are
an Android app and if you're a PC user
you're just left in the dust because
it's not supported but now like that's
that's the whole point of the web the
web works everywhere for everyone so the
promise of web bluetooth is now these
interactions with real physical devices
can happen straight from a web page
that's really powerful another really
cool thing if you see any node bots
happening around if you have a node bot
with a Bluetooth Low Energy chip you can
actually send commands to your node bot
now straight from the browser
this is amazing for education and for
like creative experimentation the
barrier to entry of talking to these
devices has just been decimated now you
may be wondering a little bit and we're
going to use this to conclude what are
the security implications of this
amazing wireless communication with
devices around us and I'm going to talk
about this a little bit remember how I
said in the beginning that it requires
user interaction before you can connect
to a device that is really important
because many of the devices out there
may not have been designed with an
adversarial attacker in mind they're
like oh it's cool it's just cell phones
or whatever you just have to install an
app but now what a webpage can talk to
my bluetooth device even worse these
potentially insecure or buggy devices
probably will never get their firmware
updated so there was a serious concern
about being able to send like nasty
packets to Bluetooth devices but there's
two defenses against this first the web
Bluetooth API is very high level so the
potential for crafting nasty packets is
is limited but also every interaction
with a Bluetooth device has to start
with an interaction with the user and
you can play a little fishing games but
it's very hard to spoof getting that
like do you want to connect to a device
dialogue now there's a couple little
nitty-gritty things that are interesting
which is that Bluetooth devices around
you can be a finger printing method like
if you have a SmartWatch or a smart TV
around you and you open up your browser
and is just able to scan willy-nilly for
devices that may be used to fingerprint
you but thankfully that's also gated
behind a user interaction finally and
this is just nice to know about whenever
you're dealing with Bluetooth or you
know radio there's a potential of
leaking your existence to the outside
world so I don't know unless you're in a
spy movie but if you open up your phone
and scan for Bluetooth devices you're
making your phone discoverable and what
that means is it's broadcasting hey I'm
here I'm a phone cool or what I'm a
phone I'm talking I'm alive anyway uh
your laptop is going to do that too when
you open up a you know web bluetooth
scan that's worth knowing about if you
want to learn more about web bluetooth i
suggest starting here the web bluetooth
standard drafting process is very open
and they
have this great document if you go to
their github with a browser support
matrix for web bluetooth and there's
also some really cool demos and like
sample algorithms offered by the chrome
team I want to say thank you to Andre
salts for creating cycle j/s an extreme
that was majorly inspiring and
influential for this talk this entire
presentation has been cycle j
application it's composed using these
streams of values and behaviors and i
also want to thank hall door who is
sitting somewhere over here for loaning
us his totally sweet bike it's would
have been possible without it so thank
you so much